l'humanité a connu des tragédies reconnu
des guerres des désastres naturels
dans quelle mesure ce que nous vivons
est un traumatisme dans quelle mesure ça
va laisser des traces profondes ou non
on a voulu en discuter avec boris
cyrulnik neuropsychiatre conférencier
auteur que l'on rejoint à paris monsieur
c'est rené que bonjour vous allez bien
comment d'abord question plus
personnelle si je comment vous vivez
vous comment avez vous vécu ces quarante
derniers jours mais plutôt bien parce
que j'ai fait moins de voyeur joue j'ai
pu travailler à mon rythme dans un
silence étonnant et le soir quand je
vais marcher un petit peu j'ai découvert
deux choses que j'avais oublié le chant
des oiseaux et l'odeur des fleurs
donc vous voyez que c'est pas une
tragédie pour moi mais je sais que pour
d'autres c'est beaucoup plus difficile
oui parce que eh bien vous avez
développé au cours des années ce concept
de résilience en va y revenir mais
d'abord dans quelle mesure d'après vous
nous vivons un traumatisme qui va ou non
laisser des traces
alors pour parler de traumatisme
il faut parler du développement
antérieures l'agression certains parmi
nous avant l'agression avait déjà acquis
des facteurs de protection
c'est à dire une famille solide une
maniement du langage et c'est un métier
donc s'ils ont un bon mais tison un bon
logement donc pour le confinement ne
sera pas un traumatisme au contraire
même ils vont recevoir s'est retrouvé le
plaisir de lire le plaisir d'écrire le
plaisir de se remettre un instrument de
musique ait eu des enfants après le
traumatisme facile processus de
résilience c'est à dire se reconstruire
d'une autre manière
à l'opposé ceux qui avant le traumatisme
avait connu une enfance maltraitée
une précarité sociale un mauvais
scolarité un métier difficile mais le
payer donc un petit logement cela
mal supporter le confinement parce
qu'ils vont être en surnombre ferme et
emprisonnés et ceux là vont vivre le
confinement comme un traumatisme mais si
on les laisse tout seul ils seront
traumatisés et ne déclencheront pas un
processus et de résider au donc les gens
qui étaient déjà vulnérables seront
d'autant plus affaibli parce que nous
vécu nous verrons voilà sur le les seuls
sortiront rarement difficilement donc il
faut prévoir déjà un mécanisme de
soutien dont les aider après la sortie
du possible à la mort du les rues mais
le confinement même pour ceux qui sont
mieux armés même pour ceux qui ont une
famille tissée un + r et même pour ceux
qui ont un travail mais pour ceux qui
continuent à voir des revenus le
confinement ça reste que ce n'est pas
naturel et non vous avez raison ce que
notre cerveau ne peut fonctionner que
s'il ya un autre autre mon cerveau n'est
plus stimulée 7 1 et 6 se moque
d'altérité dure trop longtemps il ya des
zones date roffit cérébrale c'est à dire
le cerveau une fonctionne mal et même sa
structure fini par être abîmée si l'
isolement dure trop longtemps
j'habite à toulon sur la méditerranée et
il y avait un henri laborit qui a eu son
heure de gloire au québec et il avait
mis au point des cuves à silence n'est
zone d'isolement sensorielle dans l'
isolement sensoriel tout le monde finit
par craquer c'est à dire avoir des
angoisses et même des hallucinations
mais comme je le proposais tout à
l'heure ce qu'ils avaient acquis des
facteurs de protection résistent très
longtemps et ceux qui avaient acquis des
facteurs de vulnérabilité krak oo de
quelques heures donc le confinement est
une agression
comment on distingue la façon dont
vont réagir les enfants des adolescents
des adultes ou des personnes âgées alors
c'est très différent
un enfant très rbl ne sera ne souffrira
pas du tout si son père ne souffre pas
parce que c'est sa mère qui lui qui peut
compose son premier monde et la fin
droit aucune conscience des virus si sa
mère sourit bourges de travail
il aurait ce qu'il faut pour se
débrouiller quand il accède à la parole
c'est à dire à la troisième année là ça
déteint la manière dont le foyer
parental va parler du pluvier russe si
on n'en parle pas l'enfer à comprendre
qu'il ya quelque chose d'angoissant et
il va fantasmée et imaginer le pire
mais si on ne parle que de ça on va
aussi traumatisé l'enfant donc la seule
bonne solution c'est de dire à l'enfant
il ya un danger mais on sait ce qu'il
faut faire pour le supplanter
quel geste le confinement est une
épreuve mais ça nous permettra d'être
plus fort que le virus
pour l'adolescent ça va poser un autre
problème c'est que les filles en une
avance neuropsychologiques de deux ans
sur les garçons au moment de
l'adolescence dont les fils ont déjà
armé et puis je vais me faire détester
par les féministes mais le fait de
s'occuper de sa maison plus que les
hommes est un facteur de protection
c'est à dire que les femmes se sécurise
en s'occupant en faisant des
planifications voilà mon espérance de
vie vient d'être fortement réduite
mais hélas les courriels entre sa s'est
réuni les coréens a entre autres sujets
oui mes garçons eux dont deux ans de
retard et c'est un âge où ils sont peu
de fatigue de croissance alors que les
filles 17 ans à l'adolescence sont déjà
des jeunes femmes qui ça s'organise et
planifier ce que ne savent pas encore
parler et à fond
donc beaucoup d'entre eux vont décrocher
et je sais qu'au québec comme en france
d'ailleurs le décrochage des garçons est
un problème pour les ag c'est un autre
problème c'est que ils tiennent pour la
moindre déclaration affective un coup de
téléphone un sou rien ça leur suffit
mais sissoko téléphone ne vient pas si
ce serait bien peint les arrêts de
manger ils arrêtent de boire ils se
déshydratent et immeubles et on dit sont
morts de mort naturelle ce qui est faux
ils sont morts de privations affectives
donc les relations de cause à effet sont
très différents selon les âges et c'est
ce qu'on mesure actuellement là le côté
épouvantable de ces carences affectives
j'ai les personnes âgées dans nos
centres l'essai chsld est l équivalent
de vaud simple pour personnes âgées
parce qu'on a interdit les visites
depuis plusieurs semaines déjà au congo
on laisse entrer un proche qu'on appelle
ici un projet d'art on s'aperçoit que ce
n'est pas suffisant
les gens ont besoin d'un d'un contact
minimale mais d'un contact ni au besoin
d'un contact mais actuellement se
contenter dangereux donc on a le choix
entre dedans j'ai eu le danger d'un
contact dangereux où le danger d'un
isolement mortifère donc c'est difficile
alors je crois qu'on peut trouver des
solutions c'est des petites solutions
avec le skype avec le téléphone avec des
signes amicaux avec des verres avec des
plexiglas où on peut parler sans envoyer
des baisers
souvent ça suffit ça suffit si ça dure
pas trop longtemps
mais en attendant que le virus meurt ça
suffit pour que l'eau personnes âgées
nos le meur top parce que j'ouvre une
parenthèse me cerner qu'en france dans
les maisons pour un et ça a été l'enfer
ou si oui c'était le faire parce que les
personnes c'est le première fois dans
l'histoire humaine que
il a tort de personnes âgées pour une
raison bien simple c'est que avant on
nous est très jeune
jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle en france
espérant en europe
l'espérance de vie des femmes était de
36 ans jusqu'à la découverte de 6000
vaïsse la prophylaxie de la couche mais
les hommes auraient plus vieux vers 50
60 ans pour les plus vieux quand la
retraite a été inventée bismarck a dit
dites moi quelle heure je ne verse je ne
payerai plus la retraite alors les
techniciens se sont mis au travail ils
ont dire 65 ans tout le monde est mort
davis m'a donc on mettra la retraite à
65 ans et manque de chance pour bismarck
espérance de vie maintenant et très
longue surtout pour les femmes plus que
pour les hommes
et ça change le problème donc c'est un
nouveau problème de la condition humaine
c'est l'existence et même le
développement des personnes âgées
je sais qu'aucun ça a été un problème ça
arrive en france aussi il ya beaucoup de
pays le japon où les gens deviennent de
plus en plus âgés donc avec une certaine
vulnérabilité
quand on est âgé on renforce ou l'âme on
était déjà fort c'est à dire la parole
l'histoire à condition que la mémoire
soit en contenu on a compris qu'on a
l'expérience de la vie on a compris mais
il ya des tonnes dénommait nous aussi on
est vulnérable au point muziic encore
plus le 100 m comme à 20 ans doit
surtout en devient immunodéprimées donc
le virus qui sont d'affaires laïque eu
beaucoup de gens élevé re c'est le grand
retour de l'incertitude le retourné de
la mare aussi dès la fin de cette
illusion que l'on contrôle que l'homme
contrôle tout alors c'est laid on devra
vivre avec cette incertitude un terminal
se sert une équipe il ya des gens il ya
deux il ya plusieurs cas et des gens qui
croient qu'on va se retrouver dans un
monde meilleur un peu de d'utopie là
dedans au contraire il ya des gens qui
croient qu'on se retrouver dans un monde
où l'état sera policy
on va diriger la vie personnelle déjà
vous vous en êtes tourne à la réflexion
de la praye et bien je suis comme ces
deux personnes
je pense que après il ya déjà des
économistes qui est dit il faudra mettre
les bouchées doubles pour rattraper ce
qu'on a perdu
alors c'est vrai qu' on est rude et on
aura des dettes pour 20 ou 30 ans je
sais qu'à la france est aussi rude n'est
qu'en 1945 même plus tard et il alors si
on remet en place les principes qui ont
fabriqué le virus
c'est les mêmes depuis toutes les
épidémies de peste de peste pulmonaire
de peste noire de choléra c'est toujours
les mêmes principes stocks alimentaires
transport accéléré que ce soit le la
route de la soie
que ce soit les quarantaines non
respectés pour gagner plus d'argent
qu'elles se soient laissés teinte
alimentaire pour dans les bateaux c'est
toujours le même principe donc si on se
relever consommez beaucoup faire des
stocks alimentaires et à se déplacer
beaucoup dans un an ou deux il y aura un
autre virus alors et dans ce cas là sur
le plan social
quand les gens sont sécurisés par la
certitude dites moi où est la vérité
dites moi ce que je dois faire
après un chaos social il ya toujours un
sauveur qui à rire et qui dit moi je
sais où est la vérité voté pour moi est
un très grand nombre de dictateurs ont
été élus démocratiquement et dans ce cas
là le dictateur et à l'escroc ici que
oui les gens en disant je sais ce qu'il
faut faire et c'est la tragédie
en revanche après beaucoup d'épidémie
après le siècle xviie siècle en europe a
été le siècle des peste noire il y en a
eu plusieurs répétées et après la peste
de 348 à peu la peste de 1720
il ya eu effectivement des réformes
magnifique des luttes contre les
inégalités sociales par exemple
en provence le sait le seigneur posséder
le château la terre et les hommes qui
travaillaient la terre quand il vendait
sa terre il vendait en même temps les
hommes qui était dessus c'était le
servage et les hommes étaient tellement
dominé écrasé que 10 pour tester pas
après deux ans de peste 348 1 européen
sur deux était mort
et à ce moment là il fallait courtiser
les paysans pour qu'il veuille bien
travailler se remettre faire des agrumes
elle parce que sinon on pouvait changer
le rapport où travaille sa charge et
vous êtes les crises peuvent changer
aussi vers le aller vers le mieux vers
le
par exemple une production plus local on
verra on n'en est pas là on va se
reparler boris cyrulnik ça a été un
plaisir d'échanger avec vous ce midi
vous si la soirée en france merci
beaucoup et à la prochaine
merci pour avoir voir